Für E-Autos müssen Kinder arbeiten, sie
verursachen super viel CO2 und sind sowieso
für Normalverdiener kaum bezahlbar… das denken
zumindest viele. Aber stimmt das alles wirklich?
Wir sind für dieses Video wieder einmal ganz
tief in alle wichtigen Fragen eingetaucht,
um heute die größten Mythen über E-Autos ein
für alle Mal aufzuklären. Was ist richtig,
was ist veraltet und was haben sich
Elektrogegner einfach nur ausgedacht?
Und eins vorneweg: Egal was hier bei diesem
Video rauskommt, eins steht schon jetzt fest:
E-Autos sind die Zukunft. Das ist in
der Industrie mittlerweile klar. Auch
wenn im Verbrenner-Aus Ausnahmen für E-Fuels
festgehalten wurden, will kaum ein Hersteller
nach 2035 noch Verbrenner produzieren – und das
wurde schon vor dem Verbrenner-Aus entschieden.
Die Elektrifizierung unserer Pkw ist
keine Zukunftsmusik mehr, sondern das,
was jetzt gerade passiert. Die Hersteller
machen ernst. Also: Was kommt da auf uns zu?
Doktor Whatson - Live aus der
Zukunft, so heißt meine Live-Show,
und ich komme wahrscheinlich auch
auf eine Bühne in deiner Nähe. Und
es wird da auch um E-Autos gehen. Tickets
gibt es unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Heute geht es darum, ob E-Autos wirklich so teuer
sind, ob sie für die Umwelt tatsächlich besser
sind, wo der Strom dafür herkommen soll, wie die
Rohstoffe gewonnen werden und jetzt vielleicht
die wichtigste Frage für den Alltag vieler:
Wie weit komme ich damit? Hier hört man ja
oft sowas hier: “Gestern berichtet die
Nachbarin nach einer Fahrt nach Berlin,
dass sie jetzt ohne Radio und Klimaanlage fährt,
da sonst die Batterie zu schnell leer wird.”
Behauptet zumindest “Dr. Verbrenner” auf
Twitter, also muss es ja stimmen. Andere meinen:
“Wir müssen jetzt alles mit Ladesäulen
aufbauen, erstens, wer soll das bezahlen?,
zweitens, wie lange dauert es, um wirklich
eine funktionierende Infrastruktur aufzubauen,
drittens, was machen die Leute, die in
der Innenstadt in einem Hochhaus wohnen?”
Okay. Kommen wir mal zu den Fakten:
Theoretisch können einige E-Autos über
600 km mit einer einzigen Ladung fahren. Zum
Beispiel erreicht der Mercedes-Benz EQS bis zu
770 km und der chinesische Hersteller Nio will
den ET7 bald auf 1.000 km Reichweite bringen!
In der Praxis fällt die Reichweite oft
niedriger aus, vor allem im Winter,
bei aufgedrehter Klimaanlage oder auf
der Autobahn. Das Radio hat übrigens
keinen großen Effekt. Aber immerhin
gibt es mit dem WLTP-Wert eine Größe,
mit der man verschiedene E-Autos vergleichen kann.
Und – sind wir mal ehrlich – bei den Spritangaben
für Verbrenner sieht das nicht besser aus. Der
ICCT vergleicht verschiedene Datenquellen und
kommt fürs Jahr 2019 auf einen durchschnittlich
39% höheren Spritverbrauch als angegeben.
In einer Umfrage wurden die Sorgen von
E-Auto-Käufern ermittelt. 73% davon nannten
die Reichweite, 60% das Laden auf langen
Strecken. Nach drei Jahren würden sich jetzt
98% von ihnen wieder ein E-Auto kaufen. Ich
übrigens nach vier Jahren auch. Reichweite
und Langstreckentauglichkeit sind für 99
bzw. 95% “kein Problem” oder wenigstens
“mit Gewöhnung ok”. Drei Viertel treten längere
Strecken ohne Bedenken an. Neben der größeren
Reichweite ist aber auch die Ladeinfrastruktur
entscheidend. Dann kommt man auch mit kleinem
Akku oder im Winter überall hin. Und hier hat
sich in den letzten Jahren richtig viel getan:
Die Anzahl der Ladepunkte hat sich seit 2017 mehr
als verzehnfacht, seit 2021 mehr als verdoppelt.
Und das Aufladen geht auch immer schneller:
Im letzten Jahr ist insbesondere die Zahl
der Schnellladepunkte gewachsen. Darunter fällt
alles mit einer Ladeleistung über 22 Kilowatt,
und klar: wirklich schnell ist das noch
nicht. Aber über 60% der Schnellladepunkte
bieten Leistungen von 149 Kilowatt und aufwärts
und das ist tatsächlich schon ziemlich zackig.
Auch wenn Temperatur und Ladestand die
Ladeleistung beeinträchtigen, gibt es immer mehr
Modelle, die den Akku vor dem Laden aufheizen und
so in 30 Minuten 300 Kilometer und mehr aufladen.
Oder wie wir in unserer Doku über E-Autos: Knapp
100 Kilometer in 5 Minuten, womit man dann direkt
wieder eine Stunde Autobahn fahren kann.
Nio bietet übrigens auch jetzt schon regelmäßige
Akkuwechsel an, in denen man – statt den Akku
zu laden – das Auto in eine Station fährt,
wo die Batterie durch eine andere, geladene
ersetzt wird. In Europa ist das noch keine
Alternative zum Laden, aber in China gibt
es bereits über 1.200 dieser Stationen.
War’s das? Ach ne, wie ist das jetzt für
Stadtbewohner? Aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung
ist das tatsächlich der Punkt gewesen, der mich
am meisten gestört hat. Wer nicht regelmäßig
am Supermarkt, zu Hause oder auf der Arbeit
laden kann, muss stattdessen “tanken” fahren,
und das nervt tatsächlich. Hier müssen
wir noch mehr Ladestationen bauen,
wo man regelmäßig mal ne Stunde oder so parkt.
Aber mit besserer Ladeinfrastruktur und großen
Akkus hat man eine echt gute Reichweite.
Da gibt es nur einen Haken: Größere Akkus
brauchen halt auch mehr Rohstoffe, und da
kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt. Bestimmt
hast du das auch schon gehört:
[Precht: “Lithium, das unter
entsetzlichen Bedingungen in Peru abgebaut
wird” + “Kinderarbeit, Sklavenarbeit,
da kommen die Zutaten für diese Batterien her.”
+ Indra: “Dann kommt sie in den Hochofen und wird
verbrannt. Von Recycling ist da keine Rede.”]
In vielen E-Autos sind Metalle enthalten,
die teuer und schwierig abzubauen oder ethisch
fragwürdig sind. Zum Beispiel Kobalt: Die
Nachfrage steigt stetig. Nach Angaben des Cobalt
Institute wurden 2021 34% oder 59.000 Tonnen und
damit der größte Teil des global verwendeten
Kobalts für E-Autos eingesetzt. Und Kobalt wird
von vielen direkt mit Kinderarbeit und schlechten
Arbeitsbedingungen in Verbindung gebracht.
Auch Lithium ist nicht unproblematisch.
Weil es in fast allen Akkus eingesetzt wird,
steigt der Bedarf natürlich: Von 2016 auf 2022
hat sich der Abbau verdreifacht! Lithium ist zwar
reichlich vorhanden, aber verteilt. Die Gewinnung
durch die Austrocknung von Sole kann zu Problemen
bei der Wasserversorgung führen. Neben Lithium
und Kobalt werden auch noch weitere potenziell
kritische Rohstoffe verwendet, wie Metalle der
seltenen Erden, die übrigens nicht für die Akkus,
oder Nickel. Unproblematisch sind sie alle nicht.
Aber erstens werden diese Rohstoffe nicht nur in
Batterien für Elektroautos verwendet, sondern
auch in anderen Geräten oder in der Industrie.
Wir müssen uns bewusst machen, dass jede
Form von Konsum die Umwelt belastet. Durch
die Kritik am E-Auto sind die Missstände in der
Rohstoffbeschaffung endlich in der Öffentlichkeit
angekommen – was gut ist. Aber das bedeutet eben
nicht, dass andere Produkte “besser” sind und auch
nicht, dass wir keine E-Autos bauen sollten.
Zweitens muss man die Auswirkungen auch in
Perspektive setzen. Der Wasserverbrauch für
das Lithium in einem typischen E-Auto-Akku
ist nur ungefähr so groß wie der einer
halben Jeans. Das meiste Lithium stammt
sowieso aus dem Tagebau in Australien, in
dem das Metall ohne Wasserverschwendung
gewonnen wird. Außerdem entstehen auch weitere
Projekte in Europa, unter anderem das weltweit
erste Zero Carbon Lithium. Und Rohstoffe
sind für viele Exportländer auch einfach
eine wirtschaftliche Chance. Nicht die Verwendung
an sich ist das Problem, sondern die Gewinnung.
Drittens hat sich auch hier in den letzten Jahren
einiges getan: Schon 2021 hat der chinesische
Batteriehersteller SVolt den ersten kobaltfreien
serienreifen E-Auto-Akku vorgestellt. Und auch
Tesla ist mit an Bord: Knapp die Hälfte der Autos,
die im ersten Quartal 2022 produziert wurden,
kommt schon komplett ohne Kobalt aus, weil
Lithium-Eisenphosphat-Akkus verwendet werden. Auch
BYD setzt auf LFP-Technologie. Es geht sogar ohne
Lithium: In Natrium-Ionen-Akkus wird stattdessen …
naja, ihr könnt es euch denken, Natrium verwendet,
das quasi unbegrenzt verfügbar und damit viel
günstiger und nachhaltiger ist. Damit kommt dieser
Akkutyp ohne Lithium, Kobalt und Kupfer aus! BYD
verwendet diesen Akkutyp schon, allerdings
bekommt man den Seagull bisher nur in China.
Die Hersteller haben die Rohstoffprobleme
auf dem Schirm. Und es ist gerade in ihrem
wirtschaftlichen Interesse, günstigere und
nachhaltige Batterien zu produzieren. Viel
Hoffnung ruht auch auf der Feststoffbatterie. Aber
jeder Batterietyp hat Vor- und Nachteile: Kosten,
Energiedichte oder Produktionskapazität.
Wenn die berücksichtigt werden, können in
Zukunft alle Mobilitäts-Nischen abgedeckt werden.
Trotzdem muss sich in einem Punkt noch viel tun:
Recycling. Da die Akkus oft länger halten, als
die Autos, in denen sie verbaut sind – was vielen
oft ganz anders erzählt wurde – erleben sie ein
“second life”, zum Beispiel als Heimspeicher. Und
danach könnten ausgediente Akkus eine wertvolle
Quelle für neue Rohstoffe werden. Für die nächsten
Jahre sind viele tausend Tonnen Kapazität
fürs Recycling angekündigt. Bei den Anlagen,
die es heute schon gibt, handelt es sich nach
Experteneinschätzungen aber eher um Testanlagen,
weil es bisher noch nicht
genug ausgediente Akkus gibt.
In Zukunft werden die Batterien übrigens
noch grüner: Im EU-Parlament wurde im Juni
ein Gesetz verabschiedet, das den kompletten
Lebenszyklus der Batterien berücksichtigt,
von der Rohstoffbeschaffung bis zum Recycling.
Ab Juli 2024 muss dadurch der gesamte Fußabdruck
der Batterie angegeben werden, ab 2027 soll
ein CO2-Höchstwert für Batterien festgelegt
werden. Außerdem wurden Recyclingziele
für verschiedene Rohstoffe beschlossen.
Theoretisch lassen sich schon heute fast
alle Rohstoffe aus den Batterien recyceln.
Beim Verbrenner sind am Ende der Lebensdauer
einfach 17.000 Liter Sprit weg. Oder eher:
Treibhausgase und verschmutzte Luft. Bis wir ein
so umfassendes Recycling haben, gibt es aber noch
ein paar Herausforderungen: Logistik, ausreichende
Mengen an Batterien, und viel grüner Strom.
Stichwort Strom: Dazu gibt es gleich
mehrere Mythen. Zum Beispiel wird immer
wieder behauptet, dass das Stromnetz nicht
für E-Autos ausgelegt sei. So wie hier,
oder Headlines wie “Wärmepumpen,
Solaranlagen, E-Autos:
Warum das Stromnetz an seine Grenzen kommt”
Aber stimmt das wirklich? In einem Experiment
von Netze BW wurden 10 E-Autos an Bewohner
einer Straße vergeben, die alle am gleichen
Stromkreis hängen. Damit hatte dieses Gebiet
eine Quote von 50% E-Autos, deutlich mehr,
als wir aktuell in Deutschland haben. Durch die
unterschiedlichen Tagesabläufe haben nie mehr als
fünf der Autos gleichzeitig geladen, und selbst
das nur 0,1% der Zeit! Es laden also nie alle
Menschen gleichzeitig ihr E-Auto. Deswegen
wird das Stromnetz nicht so sehr belastet,
wie es vielleicht am Anfang scheint. Jetzt werden
größere Projekte entwickelt, die ganze Viertel
abdecken. Schon 2019 hat außerdem eine Studie aus
der Industrie ergeben, dass das Stromnetz schon
damals bereit für 45 Millionen E-Autos sei,
und das ohne Ausbau. Einzige Voraussetzung:
ein intelligentes Lademanagement. Das ist aber
auch aus anderen Gründen eine super Idee. Denn
in Zukunft sollen E-Autos unser Stromnetz
entlasten, statt es zu belasten, indem die
Batterien als Stromspeicher genutzt werden und
so Schwankungen der Erneuerbaren ausgleichen.
Und genau das könnt ihr schon heute machen:
mit Tibber! Das ist ein besonders smarter
Ökostromanbieter, der sich dem Mythos der
Netzüberlastung angenommen hat und
die Schwankungen im Stromnetz nutzt,
um günstige Preise an seine Kunden
weiterzugeben – und das ohne Gewinnmarge.
Für eine Grundgebühr von 4,49 € im Monat,
gibt Tibber die an der Strombörse gehandelten
Marktpreise an euch weiter. Das bedeutet: Immer
wenn der Börsenstrompreis gerade niedrig ist,
spart ihr Geld. Ladet ihr euer E-Auto also in der
Nacht, wo gewöhnlich wenig Strom verbraucht wird,
dann ist der Strom auch günstiger.
Und manchmal gibt es sogar Zeiten,
wo ihr dank Tibber pro verbrauchter
Kilowattstunde Geld verdient!
In Skandinavien ist es aktuell sogar
schon möglich, seine E-Autobatterie mit
dem Netz zu teilen. Damit hilft man,
die Netzauslastung zu regulieren und
kann bald sogar Geld damit verdienen. Das
könnte auch in Deutschland Realität werden.
Die Smart Charging Funktion von Tibber steht
euch aber jetzt schon zur Verfügung und nimmt
euch das Micromanagement eures Stromverbrauchs
ab. Ladezeitpunkt und Ladedauer eures E-Autos
werden damit automatisch optimiert. Damit könnt
ihr bis zu 18% eurer Stromkosten einsparen!
Mit dem Link in der Videobeschreibung und dem
Code “whatson” könnt ihr euch ganz einfach bei
Tibber anmelden und direkt einen 50€ Gutschein
für den Tibber-Store sichern. Damit unterstützt
ihr natürlich auch uns und unsere Videos. Aber
jetzt geht es erstmal weiter mit unseren Mythen…
Bleiben wir beim Strom:
[Wissing-Zitat aus der FAZ: “Wir
können mit der Elektromobilität nichts für den
Klimaschutz tun, wenn wir Kohlestrom zum Laden
nutzen.” und Indra: “Dieser Strom ist nicht grün,
sondern schmutzig. Es ist zusätzlicher Strom,
und der kann nur aus kalorischen Kraftwerken
kommen. Elektroautos fahren mit Kohlestrom”]
60% der Befragten bezweifeln in einer
Allensbach-Umfrage, dass Elektroautos
umweltfreundlicher sind. Einige Kritiker
behaupten, E-Autos würden als zusätzliche
Verbraucher nur Kohlestrom verfahren und
seien damit nicht klimafreundlicher. Mit
dieser Grenzstrom-Rechnung – mehr dazu
übrigens in diesem Video – gibt es aber
gleich mehrere Probleme. Erstens: Nur weil
E-Autos “neue Verbraucher” sind, haben sie
nicht weniger Anrecht auf grünen Strom. Sie sind
nicht mehr für Kohlestrom im Netz verantwortlich
als Kühlschränke, Trockner oder Föns.
Zweitens: In Deutschland besitzen laut
einer Umfrage vom Fraunhofer ISI fast die Hälfte
der Haushalte mit E-Auto eine eigene PV-Anlage.
84% besitzen einen Ökostrom-Vertrag, deutlich
mehr als im Bevölkerungsdurchschnitt. Man
könnte also sagen, dass E-Autos den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren, gerade im Kleinen, unterstützen!
Drittens laden E-Autos nicht
nur in windstillen Nächten,
sondern das ganze Jahr über. Man kann ihren
Nutzen fürs Klima nicht an einigen Tagen messen,
an denen durch die E-Autos ein Kohlekraftwerk
mehr angeworfen wird. Wie schon gesagt,
könnten E-Autos als zusätzlicher Speicher
die Stromschwankungen der Erneuerbaren
sogar ausgleichen und damit dafür sorgen,
dass wir weniger abhängig von Fossilen werden.
2021 und 2022 ist durch die wirtschaftliche
Erholung nach Corona sowohl der Grünstromanteil
gesunken als auch die CO2-Menge pro Kilowattstunde
angestiegen. Erstmal: schlecht. Aber selbst wenn
das E-Auto mit diesem schlechten Strommix von 2021
betrieben wird, emittiert es in der Nutzung immer
noch nur die Hälfte im Vergleich zum Verbrenner.
Aber relevanter als der Strommix heute
ist ja eigentlich der Strommix der
Zukunft. Ein Verbrenner emittiert
für jeden gefahrenen Kilometer gleich viel,
egal ob jetzt oder in 20 Jahren. Ein E-Auto
hingegen profitiert von mehr Erneuerbaren
Energien, die in Zukunft ans Netz kommen.
In einer globalen Analyse hat das ICCT
die CO2-Emissionen über den gesamten
Lebenszyklus analysiert. Nach dieser Analyse
erreicht ein europäischer Kompaktklassewagen,
der 2021 zugelassen wurde, einen
Emissionsvorteil von 66-69%. 2030
und mit erneuerbarem Strom sind es sogar 81%.
[ Indra: “Ich bin sicher, dass das nicht haltbar
ist, weil der Kunde nicht mitspielt.”
“Dieses Massenverkehrsmittel wird es
nie werden” + “Da zahlt man eben gut
mal 60, 70.000 Euro oder noch mehr”]
Gut, dann lasst uns über Geld reden. Grundsätzlich
werden E-Autos in der Anschaffung immer günstiger.
Der Umweltbonus wurde zwar gesenkt, aber 2023
gibt es immer noch 6.750 Euro beim Kauf eines
E-Autos unter 40.000 Euro. In diesem Jahr haben
Tesla und andere Hersteller schon mehrfach
Rabatte von mehreren Tausend Euro angeboten.
Und je mehr Elektroautos auf dem Markt sind,
desto mehr gibt es auch auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt.
Aber dazu kommen natürlich noch Sprit oder Strom,
Parken, Versicherungen, Förderungen und so
weiter. In Untersuchungen, in denen die Total
Cost of Ownership, also die Vollkosten, betrachtet
werden, liegen E-Autos nach einiger Zeit meist
vor Verbrennern. Die E-Autos fahren ihre höheren
Anschaffungskosten also wieder ein. Wie lange das
dauert, ist allerdings je nach Fahrzeugklasse
verschieden. Für SUV und Mittelklassewagen ist
das schon nach drei Jahren der Fall, für kleinere
Wagen dauert es länger. Das liegt daran, dass sich
viele Hersteller wegen der höheren Gewinnmarge
auf teurere oder größere Wagen spezialisieren
und die Anschaffungskosten im Vergleich zum
Verbrenner bisher relativ hoch ausfallen. Im
Vergleich zum Benziner-Kleinwagen gibt es – selbst
bei langer Haltedauer – kaum einen Vorteil. In
China sind solche E-Kleinwagen schon deutlich
günstiger zu haben. Wenn chinesische Hersteller
wie BYD diese Modelle auch in Europa anbieten,
besteht also die Hoffnung, dass sich das ändert.
Ein paar kleinere Ersparnisse gibt es trotzdem
noch: Mit dem E-Kennzeichen ist in vielen
Städten das Parken gebührenfrei, teilweise gibt es
Förderungen für eigene Wallboxen und Hinweise auf
weniger Pannen. Über den gesamten Lebenszyklus
berechnet der ADAC für die meisten E-Autos zum
Teil deutlich geringere Kosten, obwohl der
Anschaffungspreis tendenziell höher liegt.
Ok, was bedeutet das jetzt? In
meinen Augen ist die Sache klar.
E-Autos starten durch die Batterie mit einem
höheren Fußabdruck in ihr Leben. Aber während
der Lebensdauer gleicht sich das durch die höhere
Effizienz wieder aus. Dabei profitieren E-Autos
von einem steigenden Grünstromanteil, und zwar
jetzt und in Zukunft noch mehr. Dass es weltweit
bei der Förderung von Rohstoffen Konflikte gibt,
ist nicht neu. Aber das passiert eben nicht nur
für E-Autos. Trotzdem muss sich da auf jeden Fall
etwas tun. Das Lieferkettengesetz ist ein Anfang,
aber wir brauchen noch mehr: Siegel für Rohstoffe
und ihre Förderung, ein besseres Recycling oder
eben Akkus ohne Konfliktrohstoffe.
Seit unserer letzten Doku zum Thema,
die ihr euch gerne hier angucken könnt, ist
nur noch eindeutiger geworden, dass E-Autos
die Zukunft sind. Durch höhere Reichweiten
und ein immer besseres Ladenetz sind E-Autos
definitiv alltagstauglich. Abstriche muss man
eventuell bei den Anschaffungskosten machen
und wenn man keine Möglichkeit hat, regelmäßig
da zu laden, wo man sowieso schon ist.
Aber – und das ist mir wichtig zu sagen: E-Autos
werden das Klima nicht retten, und das hat den
einfachen Grund, dass Autos an sich schon
schlecht sind. Mobilität mit Fahrrad, Bus und
Bahn ist oft günstiger, gesünder, und vor allem
umweltfreundlicher. Aber falls man tatsächlich auf
ein Auto angewiesen ist, auf das man auf keinen
Fall verzichten will, führt jetzt und vor allem in
Zukunft kein Weg am elektrischen Fahren vorbei.
Wie immer, bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.